the opening scene features a couple of
American tourists who visit a local pub
in Scotland as they are looking at some
old pictures hanging on the wall they
stumble upon a famous photo of the Loch
Ness monster an old man sitting nearby
tells them that he didn't sign off on
them hanging a picture of his dick on
the wall and he's upset but another old
man sitting nearby tells them that the
photo is fake and there's more to the
story eager to learn more about it they
joined the elderly man to hear the full
story as the old man begins to narrate
the tale the scene cuts to the flashback
to the year 1942 during the second world
war we are introduced to a young boy
Angus macoro who is seen staring at the
ocean he loves the sea but is afraid to
approach it because he always imagines
himself getting drowned Angus likes to
collect the seashells as he used to do
that with his father Charles being a
sailor in the Royal Navy Charles is
currently away from home serving his
country in the war and as a result Angus
misses him a lot and always counts the
days till his return one day the boy
discovers a large mysterious egg in the
sand while looking at it curiously he is
found by his mother Anne who asks him to
come back home he then puts the egg in
his bucket and accompanies his mother to
their Manor House on lock nass as soon
as they arrive Angus rushes to his
father's garden shed to hide the
mysterious egg he then washes it and
starts peeling off its top layer
revealing a shiny blue colored layer
beneath it but before he can break it
further his mom calls him prompting him
to leave the egg there and run for
dinner later that night a strong
rainstorm causes the shed's door to
start banging Angus goes to shut the
door only to discover that the egg is
hatched just then he hears a movement
prompting him to follow the sound he
soon finds a strange alien-like creature
that has emerged from the egg as he
tries to touch it the creature almost
bites him out of fear thinking that it
needs something to eat Angus grabs a
potato from the kitchen and peels it to
feed the creature this allows him to
gain its trust which makes the creature
more friend friendly however Angus is
unable to spend more time with his new
pet as he hears his mother calling and
has to return back to bed the following
morning Angus wakes up to see a parade
of military vehicles arriving in front
of their house believing that Charles
has returned Angus his sister chrisy and
their mother eagerly rush out however
they're greeted by Captain Thomas
Hamilton who reveals that the Royal Air
Force has been tasked to defend against
the potential German OTS whom they
speculate might try to invade the
country via the sea route the captain
further informs an that all the soldiers
will be staying in the manor house which
leaves her in shock she asserts that she
doesn't have enough helpers in the house
but he says that his men can do all the
work as the soldiers set up camp in the
house Angus realizes that they pose a
threat to his new pet he rushes to the
shed only to find that the creature has
messed up the entire place it's been
speedrunning puberty seeing the creature
biting his father's shoes Angus learns
that it's hungry so he runs towards the
kitchen to get something to eat however
the Army cook Sergeant Strunk refuses to
let him inside the kitchen as an
alternative the boy grabs a garbage can
and drags it to the shed the creature
immediately dives into it and begins
feeding on the leftovers am missst this
Angus decides to name the pet cruso he
then goes through an animal book to
figure out what kind of creature it is
but none of the possibilities make sense
after cruso finishes eating Angus tries
to touch his skin but finds that it's
very dry and in need of water as a
result he submerges it in water after
which the creature starts playing
happily the next day under Captain
Hamilton's command the soldiers
establish an artillery battery on a
nearby Hill to counter the threat of
German yots that have been found roaming
in nearby Waters back in the manor an
enters the shed to find the place in
total disarray while looking around a
handyman named LS mob shows up she then
tasks him with cleaning up the mess and
emptying the place and also tells him
that she suspects Angus is keeping a pet
in the shed something which he isn't
allowed to do afterwards Angus finds
Lewis emptying the garbage can freaking
him out concerned for kuso's safety he
hastily looks for it but fails to find
it the boy then fights with Lewis to
protect his father's shed however the
latter claims that the shed belongs to
him until angus's father returns from
the war as night falls Angus grabs a
flashlight and begins searching for his
pet meanwhile cruso enters the manor and
starts wandering
around it soon crosses paths with
strunk's dog Churchill who instantly
begins chasing it thank hopefully the
dog is Chained allowing cruso to
narrowly evade capture elsewhere Angus
gives up on his search thinking that
he's lost his pet but as soon as he
returns home he hears his sister scream
prompting him to rush to her room there
he finds cruso playing in her bathtub he
stops christe from shouting assuring
that it poses no threat he then confides
everything in her and also requests her
to keep it hidden from their mother on
the following day Anne goes to Lewis to
offer him some clothes belonging to her
husband the handyman politely declines
saying that Charlie will need them when
he returns in a shocking turn of events
an reveals that he's never coming back
as his ship was sunk in the war a year
ago and that he's been presumed missing
ever since she also expresses concern
over angus's struggle to accept his
father's potential demise apart from all
this she asks him to fix a plumbing
problem in one of the Manor's bathrooms
coincidentally the same one where the
kids are hiding cruso later Lewis knocks
on christe's door and the siblings try
to stop him from coming in but when he
says he'll report them to Anne she
reluctantly opens the door upon seeing
cruso in the bathroom Lewis is
momentarily startled but soon identifies
it as a Water Horse a rare creature from
Celtic folklore he further explains its
characteristics it's a genderless
creature that lays only one egg and dies
before it hatches their conversation is
suddenly interrupted when Anne knocks on
the door the siblings plead for ls's
help to hide cruso while they walk out
to buy some time the suspicious Anne
walks in anyway but finds nothing Miss
turns out that lwis has cleverly hidden
cruso in the toilet and it freaking
loves it sometime later Anne runs into
Captain Hamilton who invites her to a
feast organized by his fellow soldiers
as a gesture of appreciation meanwhile
Lewis advises Angus to release the
growing Water Horse into the sea
believing it to be the creature's
natural habitat however the boy refuses
insisting that the best place for cruso
is with him that night Anne joins the
soldiers for dinner while Angus and
christe play with crusel shortly after
they head out for some work accidentally
leaving the door open this allows the
mischievous Water Horse to crawl out of
the bathtub Churchill smells something
unusual prompting him to follow its
source not long after he tracks down
cruso and chases it around the house
causing chaos to sound of this commotion
alerts the siblings and Lewis who then
rush to find cruso the chase soon breaks
into the dining hall with Churchill
recklessly running across the table
fortunately cruso manages to escape
without being seen the creature makes
its way outside side and dives into a
fountain full of
fish Lewis instructs Angus to go back to
his room as his mother is very angry
about what just happened the boy refuses
at first but when Lewis promises to find
cruso he obliges at Dawn Lewis locates
cruso which has now become much bigger
in size he quickly awakens Angus and
brings him down to take a look making
him realize that it can't be contained
in the manor anymore as a result they
load the creature on the truck drive
towards the sea and release it into the
water when Lewis returns back to his
shed he finds Captain Hamilton waiting
for him there the captain orders him to
stay away from Angus proclaiming him to
be a bad influence however the handyman
remains unfazed in the next scene we see
two fishermen Jimmy and huie fishing in
the sea a short while later they
accidentally hook the water horse that
has now become even bigger despite being
terrified huy still wants to catch the
creature as it would bring them a lot of
money however cruso with its great
strength starts pulling their boat away
at high speed in a desperate bid to save
themselves Jimmy cuts off the fishing
line allowing the creature to swim away
on the other hand Captain Hamilton takes
Angus under his wing and pledges to turn
him into a disciplined Soldier but after
a few days of training the boy gets so
tired of his oppressive military life
that he runs towards the seashore to
meet cruso when he doesn't see it he
boards a boat and paddles himself around
a while later cruso reveals himself as a
now full grown Water Horse shocking
Angus for a moment the boy then jumps
onto its back and even though he's
frightened at first he eventually begins
enjoying the ride around the sea the
water horse also takes him underwater
drowning him instantly just kidding
making the adventure even more thrilling
this ultimately enables the boy to
overcome his fear of the water and his
need to breathe apparently as they
return back to the shore Churchill who
is on a walk with the sergeant smells
cruso and runs towards the same Angus
hurriedly asks his pet to hide
underwater but it's too late as Strunk
spots it from a distance later that
night Angus shares his adventure with
Christy and Lewis they all laugh and
seem to be enjoying themselves Anne
overhears them and peeps through the
door when LS spots her he walks out to
talk to her she thanks him for making
the kids happy because it's been a long
time since she saw them smile
unbeknownst to them they're being
watched by the captain who doesn't seem
happy at all meanwhile in a local pub
Jimmy and Huey narrate their encounter
to a reporter named jock hearing this
the reporter believes that this news can
bring tourists flocking to the town but
Huey is against the idea why'd you tell
the reporter then Huey the next day
Jimmy and jock arrive at the shoreline
to capture a picture of the creature
meanwhile Captain Hamilton takes Anne
and her kids to see the work they've
been doing so far upon arrival at the
hill the captain showcases their
Weaponry intended for use against
potential threats he then orders a
demonstration of Firepower alarming
Angus who fears for kuso's safety he and
Christy beg their mother to to tell them
to stop it but the ladder doesn't
understand what they're saying and asks
them to stay quiet the Cannons are fired
into the water many of them almost
hitting the water horse when the boy
can't take it anymore he finally
intervenes causing the soldiers to stop
unfortunately this enrages the captain
so he sends the family back home on the
other hand Jimmy and jock are also upset
thinking that the creature will never
resurface after the bombardment despite
this they decide to Stage a fake photo
of the creature to print in the
newspaper days later Strunk reads the
newspaper and identifies the monster as
what he saw earlier when he shares this
with the fellow soldiers they vow to
hunt it down Lewis comes to learn about
the Sergeant's plan and alerts Angus
about the same that night the two of
them rush to the shore and call for cruo
the water horse emerges but it seems to
be angry due to the earlier bombardment
as a result it almost bites off the
boy's hand F you Angus I thought you
were cool before retreating into the
water in the meantime the sergeant his
soldiers set sail in quest of the
creature they soon hear the barking
sound of Churchill from one part of the
shore as they approach it they're
suddenly ambushed by the giant cruso the
soldiers immediately open fire and the
creature retaliates by flipping the boat
upside down one of the soldiers manages
to send an SOS to Captain Hamilton
believing that they're attacked by
Germans the captain orders all of his
soldiers to fight back he also asks an
to keep her children safe but they soon
learned that Angus isn't home this
causes them to panic so they rush to the
Shoreline to rescue him at the shore
cruso goes Rogue and is on the verge of
eating Strunk Angus shows up in the nick
of time and tries to stop his pet when
it doesn't listen the boy Wades into the
water but he accidentally slips and
Falls unconscious seeing this cruso
Dives under the water and brings him out
Lewis then performs emergency CPR and
somehow resuscitates him as soon as
Angus opens his eyes he sees his pet in
a normal state which makes him very
happy not long after an and the captain
arrive at the scene prompting cruso to
retreat underwater Angus attempts to
explain everything to his mother but she
remains skeptical and instead accuses
Lewis of putting nonsense into her son's
head right then cruso reveals itself
leaving an and the captain in utter
shock as Angus goes close to pet the
creature the soldiers from the other
side of the shore begin firing cannons
in the water this prompts the boy to
climb onto cruso and Lead it away his
terrified mother frantically asks the
captain to stop the gunfire but their
attempts are hindered by a damaged radio
channel due to rainy weather left with
no options the captain Anne and Lewis
board a boat to go after Angus meanwhile
the soldiers mistake the creature for an
enemy submarine so they draw a huge net
to ens snare it this forces Angus and
cruso to come to a stop unsure of their
next move soon after the captain Anne
and Lewis catch up and implore Angus to
let go of his beloved pet the boy is
torn apart between his family and cruso
as he loves both of them dear ly but in
the end he reluctantly bids farewell to
his faithful companion and swims back to
his family cruso then goes underwater
and gets an extra boost to jump over the
net bringing the military equipment down
as it escapes the place Angus and the
others delightfully cheer from a
distance in the present time the old man
explains that some claim to have spotted
the water horse in subsequent years but
Angus never saw it again moved by the
story the tourists thank the man and ask
for his name with a serious expression
her replies Angus macoro outside the pub
a mother calls out to her son William
who is seen walking down the beach the
boy spots a large rock shaped egg which
has an iridescent blue shell just like
crusoe's this indicates that cruso has
left a descendant behind to carry on its
Legacy as the next Water Horse subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching